you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now and
we're heading into the weekend we're
also heading into oh the beginning of
winter next week so beautiful view a
couple of minutes ago we were looking
from Sunset Station now we're even
further to the South and to the east
this camera's on top of Black Mountain
you know when you're driving down
towards Henderson or Boulder City you
look up and there's a mountain with a
bunch of radio antennas on it that's
where this camera is and it looks all
the way across at the mountains with the
snow cover remaining and we don't see
any change they were not going to get a
whole lot of additional snow 45 is the
official temperature out at Reid
International I got 42 for Summerlin
you're a little bit warmer at the Air
Force Base at 50 and up on the mountain
Kyle Canyon checking in at 32 of course
on the other side of the mountain at Lee
Canyon the ski area is open after
getting 11 inches of snow earlier this
week and you want to talk about cold
single digits this morning at Elian only
at 16 here at noon you add 10 for Cedar
City at 26 a little bit warmer over in
Death Valley over the hunt in prep
you're at 45. bottom line all of these
numbers are a couple of degrees cooler
than they were 24 hours ago yesterday's
high 53 we're going to struggle to make
50 today and our low was right at the
freezing Mark officially many
neighborhoods into the upper 20s normal
low would be only around 40 normal high
in the mid 50s however once we get past
the official start of winter we're going
to see more spring-like temperatures
here's what's going on for your family
and friends there are still some
lingering snow showers but nothing like
the blizzard the same system that
brought us a little bit of rain really
picked up a lot of strength some
scattered showers across the Deep South
other temperatures is going to be very
cold we're talking about readings right
now in the teens for North Dakota 27 for
Chicago here's your most accurate eight
day forecast Hanukkah begins Sunday
evening 52 and that begins a warm-up
with winter officially arriving
Wednesday afternoon have a high near 60
on Thursday so stay bundled up still
chilly at night Heather Mother Nature is
a little confused Renee thank you